what's your take on youtube boxing right
now man are you uh
are you with that man are you uh
honestly i don't hate on nobody i feel
like they
they found a real life hack to the
boxing game you know and if you go in
there get your money
like you said people got to feed their
family at the end of the day if they
could do it well [ __ ]
they deserve it they sell all that the
pay-per-views and all that then
it's all good with me honestly i think
the best youtube boxers
are logan paul and jake paul yeah
because they're actually dedicated yeah
and they don't stop training you know i
mean um and i'm
just really proud of them yeah it's dope
man it's something different i mean
obviously people
are gonna get mad because they're not
some boxers including myself aren't
getting as paid as much as them but
yeah it is that's why they're here to
give you guys that exactly exactly
they open up the doors they they raise
up the purses and they're doing what
they're doing and maybe it's going to
come to us too yes
75 80 million views yeah yeah
yeah i know mike likes that man mike is
business too
what's your prediction mike uh woodley
jake paul i don't know paul's a real
good striker
and i think people's people
disadvantages when they go in and say
he's blonde and blue eye he's a white
pitch
that also that also builds that courage
up
and causes them to get knocked out
it goes back to the upgrade we were
talking about earlier there's a
motivation
you know what i'm saying like those
dudes they live in fear bro they can
flock the money they can do their [ __ ]
when you're hooked on success man you're
hooked on fear yeah no doubt oh
yeah what's up mikey give me the
philosophy uncle mike
perspective what is success you know
everybody's success is different
somebody got a billion dollars but his
success is being able to keep the stick
in his pants
you know they but still we all have
challenges you know
and everybody's everybody has a price
but everybody's price is not money
but they do have a price
the one fight i do want to see is jake
paul and austin mcbroom
but you'll see the youtubers they've
been talking a lot of [ __ ]
pull them up i think [ __ ] wrote a
tape i think jake paul slashed his tires
dude
yeah jake paul does [ __ ] like that oh
man yeah
don't just don't do it to mike just
don't do it uh uncle mike's car
that's a death sentence no i don't i
don't call for stuff like that
look at this [ __ ] who's this
these are the youtubers i fought this
which ones which ones no one is in the
orange that's mcbroom that's the one
that got his tire slash
which one is he has some pretty he has
some good all right skills too you know
oh he's stuck at the end oh man he's got
malice
he's got malice dude
[Laughter]
i mean honestly i think that would be
the biggest fight in
youtube boxers jake paul and this dude
because this dude got a big following
too
so are these two are these two selling
paper these guys right yeah they're so
paper they do make five million dollars
oh he fought a real boxer no
and who won tick tock yeah youtube
how you two one yeah how do you think
jake does with that guy he probably
knocks him out huh yeah
and that's like when you talk about me
coming back then i want to make the
money man we over here ripping it and
hot boxing dude you know what i'm saying
but you should fight this guy i'll fight
him
what's his name fight everybody
[ __ ] but listen um logan's going to beat
him
jake yeah jake yeah i beat him
yeah because i mean i just saw him i
would want to watch they both got that
beef already so you know when they got
that
b from back the back end is a beef so it
gets interesting
yeah it does it's a storyline and that's
why jake is already slashing
his tires so i don't know what else
he'll do that's a [ __ ]
yeah they still press charges yeah but
but mike do you think jake paul can be
you think he'll be woodley but willie's
not a puncher like that he's not
and his confidence is not there either
that's what i'm saying his last favorite
thing he wants to fight this guy get his
last payday yeah